- Is it true that you gave Marvel feedback
on all the Marvel movies?
- I gotta be honest,
everything that happened
in my first year at Marvel
was such a blur.
- But did you?
- But I probably did.
Every time I see a new movie,
I'm texting Kevin or Victoria,
like, "Hey, so next time
maybe try this instead,
but like you're on the right track."
- Oh my God.
- They can't say no to me now.
- Should you be in school?
- No,
I got cast on the last day of high school.
- Wow.
- What is your life?
- Perfect graduation present
considering I didn't get
one 'cause of COVID, so.
- Yeah, well, there,
you did though.
- Oh
We don't feel real bad.
- Yeah.
No one feels bad for you right now.
So wait, one of the
coolest things though is
you are Marvel's first Muslim superhero.
That's like really cool too.
Does that,
(audience applauding)
so cool.
Does it feel,
cause the inclusivity is awesome.
Does you feel pressure 'cause of that
'cause you're holding something down
all by yourself right now?
- Nope.
- I love you.
- No, I mean like,
- You know, what's great?
A Catholic, a Muslim, and a Jew.
We should go walk into a bar.
- I'm not Catholic.
- Christian.
- I'm
- Let's walk into a bar.
I know something really
funny might happen.
- There's this really great joke.
- I love it.
- It's coming.
No, but there's a lot of pressure
with being the first of anything.
I just, I don't think about it.
I can't wake up every morning and be like,
"You're the first Muslim
Pakistani superhero.
Do good, okay?
For your people."
But like, no, it's just, the
superhero part is so cool.
And it's just like working with my idols.
There's so much inspiration
and representation for
me behind the camera.
- Yeah.
- All the creatives
on our show have such
an emotional attachment
to this character and to the story
and they're bringing so much of that
and I think that's just why I'm here.
- I think it's awesome that
you are so chill about it too
because I think that's also.
I came in the industry at 19 as well
and everybody would say,
"Oh, do you feel pressure?"
And it was so funny.
I got that question, I was like, "No,
but should I?"
- Yeah.
- I was like, I would freak out
because I think people naturally
want to ask the question
but sometimes I think
when you are 19 years old,
you're just like, "I'm just
like doing what I love.
And it's like fun."
And there's no reason other than that
which is kind of really beautiful.
- Yeah. I'd do this for free.
My dad was like, "Don't say that."
- I'm sure your agent said that too.
- Her life is in insane.
- It's so weird,
so wonderful.
- I know.
- It's amazing.
You're like a dream come true, young lady.
- [Kelly] You're a home
town girl who's killing it.